the Joe Rogan experience and if you're
one of those people like me who you know
I've always loved the idea of UFOs I
became extremely weary talking to people
who are UFO believers and UFO fanatics
cuz there's so many of them they're full
of [ __ ] and not just full of [ __ ]
they're they're childishly delirious
like the way they talk about things I
mean there's so many people that are
that I'm in contact they reach me in the
night and they explain to me what we're
doing to the ocean is wrong and like you
know like okay this is one of the
reasons I didn't want to do the show I'm
sure it's no yeah well it's I mean it's
no joke we've had people literally camp
out on our front lawn and you know in
some ways I can relate to some of these
people you know maybe some of them did
really have some kind of experience or
saw something and if all their friends
think they're crazy but hey now there's
this guy I heard on the radio and
Latinos I'm not full of [ __ ] so I got a
talk to him and so most of the
correspondence I get are people trying
to get a hold of me come on Bob you you
gotta listen to me I'm I'm coming to
talk to you I'm you know I'm driving
from Oklahoma or whatever and and ends
but some of them are just [ __ ]
batshit crazy I'm yeah they're
frightening there's a lot of
schizophrenic that are involved in the
conspiracy world there's a lot of people
that have real issues so I it would be a
disservice to your audience to not say
that we have to look at what's going on
now and understand I've heard you on
your show a bunch of stuff about what's
going on now and to not really
understand what's going on now you can't
see Bob's story in the correct light
after 30 years and at some point we
should just touch upon that the the
biggest being that things like the
tick-tack UFO case that came out I've
heard people even on the show say oh
there's a glitch in the radar that's a
data poor perspective you just don't
know yet what's really going on
commander Frey ver I was able to get the
interview with him to talk with him way
before it became public
I I got that from him he saw it other
pilots saw it this is a big thing that's
going on right now
they had more sightings on the East
Coast recently cubes with with spherical
or C's are not aerodynamic and these are
the people we trust to defend us on 9/11
commander favored protected Los Angeles
on 9/11
so we trust them but they're not trained
observers radar individuals see these
things and the big the big one just to
throw down so we can consider a story a
little differently there's more depth to
it the big one is the United States
government has admitted that they have
been continuously studying the UFO
phenomenon that program was called a tip
advanced Aris or sorry was called AUSA
that that's the mother program George
Knapp got that out they announced
through the New York Times about a tip
but all set these acronyms awesome
advanced aerospace weapon systems
applications program who cares that was
the mother program so they've admitted
we didn't stop studying UFOs in 1969
with Project Blue Book we don't think
it's crazy we're actually want to
reverse engineer the technology that's
why on your other show you said what's
this AAV thing it's like they're making
up another UFO name well hold on there's
a reason because in the documents the
DIA documents that George Knapp released
that everybody said was fake till now
they know is real they call them a AVS
which is advanced aerospace vehicles
people are getting acronyms wrong so
they're the reason for the terminology
change is so that we can mimic what
we're reading in the DIA documents
people can look for that now so they
changed the names to get people away
from UFO or UAP even like Hillary
Clinton said on air right so what are
you talking about
Hillary grunts um Hillary Clinton
informed the public on Jimmy Kimmel Oh
Jimmy we don't call them UFOs anymore we
call them UA AP's unidentified aerial
phenomenon right so she kind of was
giving to their the Clintons are very
into the UFO topic
Senator Reid you know he he's done a lot
for the for the subject the study of it
right so she informed the public so they
could look for the right term so these
terms are important because the DIA in
those documents they've been calling
them a vs for quite some time now and
they changed the name to anomalous no
that that's kind of miss no no so it
they always mess around with things but
it's actually advanced right
climbing in in the news they were
calling an anomalous vehicle totally and
that's cool they were also saying
anomalous aerospace threats aat right
because they want the sense of a threat
right so my point is all of it if people
don't know this now and they think this
stuff is is fantasy this this part of it
that we're studying it that we take it
seriously we're spending money on it and
that we're getting great data from from
visual pilots to to radar that's why we
know it's aerospace they dropped from
80,000 feet but guess what that's the
top scope of the spy-1 radar is 80,000
feet so the radar system they were using
it was coming from above that so my
point is this
if you don't understand that this is
happening you're just behind the curve
because you don't have the information
because of the stigma that you're
talking about I saw you get totally
upset with the UFO topic I met you first
when you get totally upset with UFO
topic it's the people when when you're
doing your I'm sorry man when you're
when you're doing your show you know the
jargon questions everything I could see
how how frustrating is trust me I have
been frustrated too how luckily my
mentors George Knapp and he's taught me
the Pitts Paul pitfalls as I went
through it my whole point in this rant
right here is just that we have to now
look at Bob's story but knowing the
facts not someone saying it's a bird
it's a plane it's a glitch they're not
and so if you don't know that you just
don't have the information you're not
just that knowing the facts as we know
them in 2019 not 1988 absolutely
[Applause]